salut à tous ces pêcheurs de trainer
l'or aujourd'hui à béziers admettront
préférées alors non on est tous les deux
avec un cameraman stagiaires donc il ya
alex qui va sûrement nous rejoindre et
le but ça va être de dépolluer la faune
et bars sont retrouvés sous sur le plan
donc pour très empruntée par les
voitures les rangs des dingueries il y
aura sûrement des choses intéressantes
en attaque tout de suite
ça vient ça vient ça vient
aussi une nulle
à quoi que un c'est bizarre il donne des
droits
mais ouais c'est quoi ce projet c'est
pas nous c'est un morceau de voitures du
court
sortir un nom il ya enfin bon ça
c'est pas mal quand même le frein à main
vos mots de vitesse
500 interventions du pont pour mesurer
niveau de
ayala règles de
suspension des gros cailloux avec un
intéressant si
on avait fait exactement la même avec
spotify en plongeant pas l'air vide elle
était pleine haussier
vos télécommandes et leurs livres au
csna tchad
au fond elle est pleine ouais vas vite
et cela c'est la bonne ça va bien mais
ou
ceux là surprise da dans l'herbe ah oui
et cadres de scooter en entier
joli bravo
ouais belles trouvailles
une pièce annoncé une pile trois lithium
s'expliquer avec sa copine alors
à sympa
ouais
à légiférer
c'était un beau but chose est inscrite
au bout
bien sûr ça c'est la trouver de la
journée ça
qui le
rêve bravo il est plein aussi
ouais c'est peut-être l'eau qui rentre
ça ce serait un peu débile de jeter sa
place
comme un cerveau sont une trentaine
d'euros
du coup était petit et manger repéré
plein de choses là non là où il ya des
gens qui veulent
voilà tu devrais aller voir
ailleurs
atteint un truc à bata encore une
bouteille encore une bouteille de
protoxyde donc c'est la quatrième ça
pollue un il ya du plastique et oulad
dans un scandale ce qui jette ça quand
même
et les lieux il pourrait signifier la
bouteille arrêt allait regarder comment
explosé en droit une cartouche
dommage ça encore
il ya vraiment quelque chose de gros
encore ce côté
owen a senti venir
ah oui oh là
haut ça c'est de la moto ça c'est de la
moto c'est la
jolie très beau cadre de 125 en pense il
a été découpé mais très bonne état quand
même
belle trouvaille
there de trois heures dans le sud de la
france si j'avais une piste un
commentaire bon ça vient là où c'est
lourd
ça lâche et oui il ya un gros truc
indélébile regarder
ouais bah même avec le bis peut-être
andreu pouvoir vas-y balance à valence
mais non c'est la
ola et gilbert montagné toi
au regard d'une canne à pêche
ne chante pas
c'est une demie canne à pêche
une canette canapé shui regarde un mec a
fait un plomb avec une pierre
yacé nos pêcheurs ont du talent on à la
corde coincé donc on va voir ce qu'il ya
une rotation
au revoir
aux serrar sa photo sur l'orb
un câble à huit mois que l'idh
[Musique]
qu'il est bon le pont c'est dangereux je
pense alors tu vois bosser comme un
ouais comme un fil de fer mais s'est
fait assez large comme ça
[Musique]
une barre à mine qui va sauter
hall est comme ça
ouais alors bâtisse a une idée il veut
qu'on accroche deux cordes ensemble il
va les jeter à manier le barbarian à la
nage ou mieux là bas comme ça on va
pouvoir ramener sur une grande distance
ainsi que ça donne ouais c'est parti à
vis du plan logique et elle coule des
piquets
émotion ses amitiés
et fegafoot geste rires eh ouais il
arrive tu plonges le ballet et de une
corde
déroulement de la deuxième
médaille a dit
ayad et pietrus que moi
donc tout ça vient des profondeurs de
l'orb donc là il ya un
couteau médiévale
ouais hélas ce que tu veux que toi
et des cailloux
aux jolies le guidon passé mais l'eau ça
ouais sympa du plastique
un chez bull prend la dépollution lé
bella par contre à bras ouais
[Applaudissements]
non la base
treuil troy treuil non essais à 4
d'abord hausser mastoc
je crois
ça peut être un coffre ou quoi n'ont pas
tous un un peu 2 3
1 chômage les enceintes là vous entendez
le sont
[Musique]
le
et m
[Musique]
la paire des leçons bayat et au rock et
va faire du kayak dédicace à toi mon
pote qui n'a pas voulu coucher avec
j'espère qu'ils vont encore perdre en
finale
bon du coup ils sont tous sens posent là
sauf le stagiaire bizarrement
et moi j'ai attrapé le gros truc et je
vais essayer de me leroux mené tout seul
je vais pas y arriver les gars on
regarde c'est un barbecue je crois
j'ai vu une grille
j'ai bien ramener là il est juste là
baptiste
mais bolat à bière
non veulent pas le vendre et courtois
les poussent à agir
wet seal a vraiment aussi jo wil à
l'envers la regarde
[Musique]
ça peut faire un barbecue non j'ai vu ça
oui en fait il a dû tomber du pont deçà
d'autres un accident
j'ai déjà vu une vidéo où il met les
mecs dans les caddies way et il s'amuse
tu vois et après ça tape dans leur bord
du pont elle a dû tomber
le caddie dérape métaux dedans et on
tour rejette mais en plus si les anciens
qu'a dit ça parce qu'il a way et en plus
ils sont ils sont petits maintenant ils
sont plus gros pour inciter à quoi
consommer plus
il peut servir à tout moment j'ai un peu
peur quelqu'un a chuté
jerry brice de nice version roumaine
joly
[Musique]
je me pose une question là est ce que je
nomme abonnés à l'offre comme la
dernière fois on avait dit de s'abonner
seulement c'était un truc aimante et que
c'était pas aimanté vous n'êtes pas
abonné à la dernière vidéo on recrée
abonnez-vous à celle ci c'est pour me
lâcher le petit coup de mou le
commentaire tout ça pour le
référencement
vous connaissez chercheurs de trésors on
aime bien se poser pas mal de questions
surtout quand ça parle de pollution de
nos rivières et de gros sous on a donc
voulu en savoir un petit peu plus sur ce
fléau qui polluent nos rivières en effet
ce n'est pas la première fois contre ce
genre de cartouches on a cru beaucoup la
semaine dernière aussi en plongeant en
centre ville donc voilà on sait on s'est
vraiment dit qu'on allait essayer de
remonter à la source de la lentille soir
là pour comprendre un petit peu plus ce
qui se passait vous connaissez tous le
protoxyde d'azoté ou proto donc c'est un
gaz qui se vend souvent capsules et qui
a des propriétés hilarante mais qui de
base est utilisé pour les siphon à
chantilly ou même pour la crème
chantilly qu'on achète en supermarché
il est commercialisé sous différentes
formes donc vous avez des petites
capsules mais vous avez aussi des
bonbonnes et on voit d'ailleurs de plus
en plus de ce type de bombes au delà
donc comme sa vie nous avons de vrais
dans la vidéo
bien sûr s'il ya des effets qui comme
elle disait alors on sait depuis
longtemps que le protoxyde d azote ça
provoque ce qu'on observe là en ce
moment sur les troubles neurologiques
parce que c'est des maladies qu'on
voyait surtout chez des personnes qui
travaillaient en bloc d'anésthésie
maintenant plus fous dans cette histoire
j'ai envie de dire c'est pas forcément
les conséquences que ça sur les
personnes mais c'est plus le business
incroyable qui gagnèrent tout ça autour
de cette de cette drogue légale 2.0 on
va dire donc vous voyez ces inscriptions
sur la bouteille queen de luxe c'est
tout simplement la marque donc il ya
quasi monopole à l'échelle française
voire à l'échelle européenne sur le
marché donc bien sûr c'est une marque
qui n'a aucun scrupule à vendre un un
poison pour pour les jeunes de manière
tout à fait tout à fait légal est tout à
fait on va dire un contrôle et qu'enfin
petit tour sur le site de l'entreprise
on peut voir qu'elle se présente comme
une start up innovantes qui cherchent à
fournir des solutions faciles et
innovante encore une fois dans le
secteur de la restauration
la restauration bien ça les amis c'est
un petit peu le le alexandre benalla du
siphon à chantilly en fait on va dire
qu'ils ont plus là pour pour défoncer
des cerveaux que pour faire de la
pâtisserie enfin ouais on voit on voit
déjà le problème quoi cette boîte qui se
vend comme une boîte qui est là pour
révolutionner le monde de la pâtisserie
ça arrivait encore plus notre curiosité
et on s'est dit qu'on allait pousser un
petit peu plus nos recherches là dessus
et on a des voix pas mal de choses
intéressantes
donc vous pouvez voir que cette
entreprise est basée à amsterdam voilà
n'ont pas trop de soucis à vendre de la
drogue pour le coup ils sont amsterdam
donc je pense qu'à ce niveau les
législations et sont encore plus
tranquille que ce qui peut mettre en
europe à vendre du proto ils sortent
bien sûr sur une tendance majeure donc
une vague sur une vague à l'échelle
mondiale et génère un chiffre d'affaires
colossal de plusieurs millions d'euros
parce qu'ils ont bien sûr ils ont ils
ont plusieurs marquise ont ils n'ont pas
seulement club de luxe ils ont par
exemple smart pipes ils en ont plein
d'autres dans différents pays et
justement il sort tout petit peu sur
cette idée de faire des petites boîtes
un peu partout et présenter ça comme des
start up c'est vraiment génial et est
bien sur l'idée principale c'est de se
spécialiser dans la vente de gros donc
voilà c'est des boîtes qui vont pas se
mouiller qui vont pas à les vendre au
consommateur avoir des risques c'est de
la vente de gros donc ici vous savez des
lots énorme et vous avez en fait des
revendeurs qui vont acheter ça pour
essayer de revendre donc ici par exemple
quand on va sur le site de clown de luxe
on a on a l'eau de 48 cartouches de 615
g vendu 1200 47 euros donc ça nous force
après 26 euros la cartouche et voilà
regardez je suis même éligibles au code
promo 10% voilà génial le tout opérer en
toute légalité de nokia aucun souci à
commander ça sur internet et bien sûr
sur la vente est réservé à une clientèle
majeur voilà c'est le seul frein à
l'entrée c'est ça et puis c'est pas un
problème puisque en fait comme je lé 10
et ils vont passer par des revendeurs
qui achètent en gros et qui ensuite se
chargent de redistribuer ça en ville
donc on s'égare un peu revenons à nos
moutons et cherchons à comprendre la
provenance des cartouches que nous avons
retrouvée nous dans l'eau donc on l'a
dit c'est pas lui qui vend ses
cartouches mais en fait elles sont des
codes snapshot affiché dessus donc voilà
si vous avez cartouches et nous on fait
on a réussi à contacter la personne sur
snapshot le livreur on va dire ce qui
ressort principalement de notre
entretien avec lui c'est l'idée qu'en
fait il est juste là pour acheter et
revendre que ce que font les gens des
capsules c'est pas trop son problème il
aimerait bien que ce soit moins jeter
dans la nature il est d'accord avec nous
sur ce point là oui bien sûr ça ferait
que son activité sera un petit peu moins
voyantes et donc ils auraient moins de
risques d'avoir des ennuis il nous a dit
qu'il n'était pas du tout le seul à
faire ça dans notre ville et encore
moins à l'échelle de la france qui avait
vraiment des dizaines de personnes qui
avaient ce type de business model la
semaine sur ce n'a pas faire des codes
et à et à rayonner un petit peu dans
leur ville en tout cas j'espère que ce
format de petites enquêtes vous a plu
n'hésitez pas encore une fois a lâché un
petit pouce bleus et à nous suivre pour
la prochaine vidéo de pêche à leyment
dans laquelle j'espère qu'on trouvera
beaucoup moins de ces capsules